fear not everyone because cbs8 has given
us the fact check that amid the Israel
Hamas War and the deployment of 2,000
additional Marines and sailors into a
region and warships US military draft
not returning amid Israel Hamas War oh
cuz that's that's the question everyone
had already asked I love this pre-b this
is what they call it the Pre-K they call
it a pre-b I'm not kidding would they
put out a fact check before the story
actually hits for this reason yeah there
wondering that if in case you were
wondering I mean it makes sense that's
that's the obvious first question if if
no one is enlisting in the military
partially because no one is qualified to
enlist in the military that's one of the
biggest deterrence there are people who
would want to and they just don't meet
any of the fitness or mental health
requirements so on top of that we don't
have enough people then the draft is the
only way to get around those standards
exactly I I had read a statistic and I I
you can't quote me on it but it was
something like 70% of gen Z like
wouldn't qualify for the military
because everybody is sick and everybody
is fat it's Sick Fat anxious you go to
Google and has allergies to weird stuff
yes you go to Google and you search for
US military draft and there's just tons
of Articles making sure everyone knows
there will not be a military draft you
want to know what that makes that
there's definitely a draft there's
definitely but how could there not be
this makes me think this makes me think
that they are going to have one but
right now they're telling you no no
we're not going to have one but then
something huge has to happen where
everybody's going to get behind it and
say yeah like another 911 and they say
oh yeah we be worse has to be worse it
does absolutely at this point see I or
maybe not with with 911 the issue was
that Americans felt attack so a bunch of
people were like I've got to do my duty
and defend my nation so they enlisted
little do they know that they're going
to be sent to Iraq and Afghanistan for
nation building projects but uh the the
the people who enlisted and signed up
for this that was completely Noble and
then you have corrupt powers that beat
it be that exploit manipulate well that
was Des santis that's when DeSantis
signed up considering that we're in Dire
Straits now militaristically like
recruitment rates are really really low
it may not be it may not be so much
about it it may just be they're going to
force people to do it right with 911 you
had people who are willing to do it if
something like that happens now right we
got all this reporting about open border
and potential Terror attacks with and
and and and the war that's happening in
in in the Middle East yeah they might
just be like we have no choice however
it will be they there will have to be
something 911 ask well it would be like
Vietnam remember how I mean there were
so many young men who got called up to
Vietnam who had no idea what they were
doing and ended up just being
essentially massacred like that was a
pretty horrible situation and because we
had a lot of um we had weak nationalism
at the time um and we had a bunch of men
called up who didn't know what they were
doing and I think that the young men we
have now are probably far less qualified
than my father's generation was to go to
to Vietnam yeah I mean they regularly
fail Basic Fitness tests I think it's so
I I've been talking to some members of
special ops military forces for story
I'm working on and it's interesting
because if you from the anecdotal
evidence that I have you know people who
want to be in Special Force they want to
be Green Berets they want to be Navy
Seals they tend to be even more Elite
those standards have gone up just
because of who is electing to be a part
of them it's you know division one
athletes it's former professional
athletes people who are in the best
shapes of lives but just the Infantry
which is really what all branches of the
military need these basic levels uh
those standards are lower and they're
regularly missing their recruitment
goals I mean right and the military is
in a position where they are beginning
to sort of alter their reporting numbers
to make it look like they're not doing
as badly as they could as we go into the
brink of World War III I mean it's not a
good position there is no way they don't
end up drafting people if they
ultimately decide we are I I do think
that there's a difference though as well
like I think that if the United States
were attacked as it was with 9911 which
is a different situation than fighting
in Foreign Wars I think that if there
were um you know there's there has been
talk of these some what five million
illegal immigrants who have come into
the us since Biden took office that
there could be Terror cells among them
we have seen the um the the great
numbers of single young men entering the
country with no real Rhyme or Reason as
to what they could possibly be doing
here if we started seeing that kind of
suicide bombings or you know terrorist
attacks that you know Hamas Unleashed on
Israel in what like the late 80s and
into the 90s if we started seeing that
in the US I think that you would see
nationalism go up I think that a lot of
young people would be like I'm going to
fight for America because the the fight
has come to America but I do think that
there is a lot less of an appetite to
send our children to go fight in Foreign
Wars under this idea that we're
protecting democracy when we're watching
our own democracy and our own Nation
fall apart I totally agree I think I
think there would be people who would
say I want to defend America but I think
they would be less likely to enlist and
get deployed far away they would want to
stay close to their families you might
see an increase in like maybe the
National Guard but even that could be
deployed internationally I think people
if we saw an increase in in domestic on
the ground in US tax the desire to
protect would be there I just think it
would be a deterrent from joining the
military and they wouldn't join they
they'd form a militia for a mil if we're
seeing you might people join local law
enforcement but I think the chance that
you could be deployed away from your
family when you know there's an increase
in in domes it would be hard to it would
also be hard to join local law
enforcement the kind of laws that we've
seen enacted against law enforcement
officials um has been pretty grave in
the past several years I mean the the
defund the police movement was
shockingly effective not just in
actually pulling funds by city council
of police departments but changing the
laws across the board we had a report
this morning I came in to work this
morning uh I turned on my phone and I
was at work but I came in is crazy right
it's crazy um but yeah Ari Hoffman put
this report together about uh this uh
911 call in Seattle that was made public
and on the call it showed that um there
was like a domestic abuse situation the
guy was beating up this woman she was
like trying to get to her kid and
protect her kid or whatever he drags her
into the car uh forces her to drive
she's being pursued by police officers
and the police officers call off the
pursuit cuz they're like oh we're not
actually allowed to pursue unless
there's probable cause of something and
they're afraid to pursue that's true I
think not just Seattle but in Chicago I
think as well that's what was going on
it's like the police officers aren't
allowed to give chase after a certain
point so the morale has got to be really
low and there are you know like Police
recruitment is low police recruit mment
is low and that's a big part of it too
like in New York City they have been you
know cutting funds mayor Adams has been
threatening to cut funds for police
officers and kids who are enlisting and
thinking about joining a militia they do
have to know their constitution well
because the government the federal
government does have the right to call
up um call up the militias to to fight
they're that's R but it's but it's yes
and if we if we operate under the
traditional sense of militia that would
matter but all that really means is
conscription cuz militia back in the
wasn't so organized it was just the
local men in the area would take up guns
and they'd fight if they if they had to
I think what we'd end up seeing is is if
there were taxs in the United States
people would look to their neighborhood
watch or the neighborhood leaders and
just be like tell me where to stand they
wouldn't sign any papers or do anything
formally which would make it really
difficult for the US government well you
know that's go ahead J I'm sorry no it's
okay so so really everything so when it
comes to war in the Constitution it's
written on a defensive stance so it's
article 4 section 4 and it it says that
it's the federal government's duty to
protect the states from Invasion and I
mean we're in one there's been declared
one you know but that's really the only
that's the only thing it says doesn't
say anything about offense at all all
that that's interesting about protecting
States from Invasion because so many
states have been Invasion invaded by the
federal government's policies with this
illegal immigration thing like why I I
find it perplexing that states aren't
standing up for themselves more you have
New York City being like hey it's too
much well New York City is like come
help us federal government whereas Greg
Abbott in Texas is like I am invoking my
right to Def
Tex and then they're like stop doing
that immediately stop I think that's the
craziest thing I mean we probably all
followed it for so long but with that uh
floating buoy barrier at first they were
like it's not humanitarian people could
drown he's like yes we should deter them
from swimming and potentially drowning
and they're like we've changed our mind
you were supposed to get Congressional
approval and then he was like but no I
don't need that I'm I am here to defend
Texas and I think that's this weird
position the Biden position the Biden
Administration is walking in you'll get
them you know authorizing through
mayorcas uh more construction of the
border wall and then they immediately
walk it back because their policies are
hurting the country and they know they
have to act because not only is New York
suffering but Texas is suffering there
no one is going to stand by them in this
next election cycle if they don't do
something on the other hand they said
they wouldn't uh build the wall and so
they look like Hypocrites because they
are they're only sort of building it and
they're building it not in the necessary
places from what I understand never do
anything right but yeah so Chicago
actually had um they had the residents
of Chicago the black the black residents
and they were cuz I guess they're
sending a lot of migrants to Chicago I
love that the black res black residents
like no no get out of here they're like
we already get the crumbs and you want
the crumbs of our crumbs like I sort of
had this idea when I saw that when I saw
those people standing up in Chicago I
was like maybe all us Americans can
remember that we're all Americans and
we're all on the same team and we don't
have to like be div divided up by these
racial segregated ideas like you know
black Americans are Americans and you
know like white Americans are Americans
and well and illegal immigration Latino
Americans are Americans and like we're
here let's protect our country can we do
that together we used to be a Melting
Pot and the answer is kind of no we I
mean thing is illegal immigration hurts
impoverished communities more because it
adds an additional burden to a community
that's already struggling so it makes
sense to me that people who would feel
as though they are disadvantage would
then be like please close the border
this is not helping us it's just
marketed as this thing like you're so
you're so mean and they're just coming
here because there is economic turmoil
on their country and ultimately we know
that that's not the case like in slim
cases people are seeking uh Asylum but
it's not the wide majority that the
Biden Administration would like it to be
let's let's and then you're destroying
Queens with a brutal sex trade thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net